you can't get all the nutrients out of
meat you can't and fiber all of us think
fiber is is one of the nutrients of note
that people aren't getting enough of
already there's no fiber in meat there
are so many nutrients that you need to
get from a varied diet a varied diet
that we all evolved on forever had all
the food that was available but to focus
on one food group alone yeah I just
after all my years of training I there's
no way I could support that what do you
say to the person who says all this
stuff about elevated LDL is
misunderstood my first major paper was
on LDL particle size so I've actually
known about this since
1996 when apob goes up it's probably
more powerful than LDL cholesterol the
number of particles you have and on a
carnivore diet or a ketogenic diet it's
up and clinically from everything I know
it's not good for you you can't dismiss
this with particle size